Selamlar sevgili dostlar. Umarım
iyisinizdir. Sağlık, sıhat, ailenizin
sağlığı, hepinizin sağlığı iyidir. İş
arıyorsanız güzel iş fırsatları
sizinledir. İnşallah çalıştığınız
ekiplerde de emeğinizi karşılığını
alıyorsunuzdur. Güzel featurelar
geliştiriyorsunuzdur. Şimdi eee flight
booking serimiz yani refactoring master
class serimizin 6. partındayız eğer
yanlış saymadıysam. Bu sefer arkadaşlar
eee time konusunu irdeliyoruz. Bu sefer
işte tema altyapısı, colorlar, işte
tipografy, padding vesaire. Şimdi bu
aslında videodan sonra artık tavır
değiştirmeyi de düşündüm ve artık
tamamıy AI bazlı AI'ın da bize verdiği
güçleri size ben bunları biraz
configlerle hazırlayıp vermeye devam
edeceğim. Çünkü artık hepimizin bildiği
gibi yani baştan sona kod yazmanın bir
anlamı yok. Ben daha çok böyle bir
sayfada belirli başlı şeyleri size hemen
hızlıca göstereceğim. Diğer kalan
kısımları da vereceğim promptlarla size
göstereceğim şekillerle size en azından
özellikle fikri ben nasıl düşündüm siz
de kendi projeleri düşünmeniz şeklinde
anlatmaya devam edeceğim. Bu sayede hem
kendi projenizi hızlı entegre
edeceksiniz hem fikri alacaksınız. Ondan
dolayı arkadaşlar bu projede önceden
hazırladığım bazı şeyler var. Özellikle
dokümanın altında prompllar koymaya
başladım. Mesela tema extension bu
konuyu nasıl oluşturduğuma ait. Ben şu
an bunu Türkçe yaptım ama bunu siz
istediğiniz şekilde değiştirebilirsiniz.
Daha iyi anlayın diye. Eee, tema promp
koydum mesela. Bu prompt sayesinde alıp
istediğiniz herhangi bir eyet yoluyla
eee, benim bu yaptıklarımın birçoğuna
anlık olarak erişebileceksiniz.
Bir yandan mesela skill ayarladım.
Skillerle ilgili de yani ben çok e bazlı
içerik üreten olmadığım için
araçlarınızda birçok şey karşınıza
çıkacaktır. Hızlı hızlı her defasında
hani promptı vermeme adına skill setimi
de oluşturdum. Yine bu projede buna
erişeceksiniz. Eee, ana bir team MD
dosyam var. Bunu anlatacağım. neden bunu
yaptığımı eee ve genel konsepti bu
şekilde basitçe özetlemiş olayım. Şimdi
arkadaşlar bu Flatter projesindeki
özellikle tema olayı zaten olayın en can
alıcı noktası. Yani projede doğru
kurulduğu zaman çok rahat edeceğiniz,
yanlış kurulduğu zaman her yere
gidebileceğiniz bir nokta. Ben şu an
sizi özellikle en çok kullanılacakları
ve neye dikkat etmeniz gerektiğini şöyle
basitçe birkaç kelimede göstereceğim.
Ama tabii ki gerçek hayatta karşınıza
çıkabilecek birkaç sorun da oluşacak.
Onlara da birkaç tane yine önlem aldırıp
sizlerin karşısına çıkacağım. Şimdi
arkadaşlar en temel konsepte tema sadece
temadan ziyade ben mesela radiusları da
ele aldım. Eee size da burada en önemli
olan nokta projenin belli bir yani belli
bir structure olması lazım. Mesela bu
nedir? En basitinden size genelde 4'ün
katları olması. Mesela renklerin belli
bir şemada gelmesi, paddinglerin belli
bir yine eee size setleriyle olması
vesaire. Bunların hepsini başta doğru
kurgularsak devamı zaten akacak. Şimdi
bu benim bozuk olan sayfam bu arada.
Şimdi ben size oluşturduğum benim o
fikirle projelerimde kendi projelerimde
kullandığım o yapılardan en basitinden
başlayarak ileriye doğru gideceğim.
Şimdi arkadaşlar benim aslında en temel
konsepte iki tane tema oluşturmuş
oluyorum ben projemde. Bir tane lighta,
bir tane dark tema ve bu dark'ın robotu
zaten defaultta flutterım var.
İsterseniz font family yükleyip oradan
da alabilirsiniz. Bunları en başta
burada eee bir static class aracılığıyla
burada ayarlatıyorum. Şimdi burada
mesela getter yapmak eee mesela bu eğol
bunu böyle yapmış ama bu aslında bunu
şöyle yapmak daha güzel. Çünkü zaten bu
tema aslında bir kere oluşacak ve
projede ömür boyu aslında bir daha
değişmeyeceği için aslında bunu final
tanımlayıp şu şekilde yapmam benim için
daha hoş olacak. Ama eee burada ne almış
şurada? App Color şema light demiş. Şunu
nerede kullanmış şemayı? Şöyle de
yapabilirdi mesela.
Şöyle diyebilirdim.
Dur mesela şunu alayım şuradan sevgili
dostlar. Şöyle koyduğumda
static final light tamamı verdim. Team
data
bu neye kızdı bu?
Yook. Bir saniye. Doğru kurguladım
aslında.
Şunu sileyim.
Şu yukarıda bir şey klasam. Bir saniye
bir geri alacağım. Orada bir karmaşa
oluştu. Hemen kodu düzelteyim. Şu light
dark derken statik aslında olacak şey
şöyle bir şey olacaktı aslında. Light
niye kaydıysa orada ismini mi kaydırdım
acaba? Bilmiyorum. Light 2 diyeyim şuna
da. İsimlendirmesi kaydı. Neyse bu
şekilde de aslında tanımlayabilirsiniz.
Yani aslında bunu finale tanımlamak daha
mantıklı get yaptığında çünkü her
defasında temayı bir daha calculate
etmesi gerekecek. Bunu en azından finalı
bir kere memoride hesaplatıp bir daha
yarmamemesi açısından hani tavsiye
ettiğim kesinlikle bu. şu anlık hani o
tarafı öyle yapmış da bunun içerisine
girersiniz. Neyse orayla ilgilenmiyorum
şu an. Burada önemli olan nokta benim
color setlerimi ve aslında kullandığım
text temayı da başlangıçta belirleyip
verip eee projenin ilerleyen aşamasını
tekrar tekrar tekrar üzerine konuşmadan,
üzerine tartış üzerine eklemeler
yapmadan devam edebilmek. Şimdi ondan
dolayı buradaki tema setini zaten burada
set ediyor olacağız. Burada benim yine
colorlar ve tema üzerinde ve textler
üzerinde oluşturduğum birkaç tane
constant class ve bunun dark light
olarak tanımlattığım iki tane yeri var
aslında. İşte color şemada da arkadaşlar
şurada aslında benim öncesinden yine bu
palet üzerinde tanımlattığım e bir tane
yine bunu yine bu final yapmakta fayda
var bu arada mesela bu bunu böyle yapmak
çok doğru değil. Paletlerim var. Palette
de işte şu an dümenden bir tane
abstraction'la yaptığım bir ana kalları
kullandığım yerim var. Bunun içerisinde
dark ve light olarak doldurmak üzere
hazırladığım color setim var. Bunu kendi
projenizde strike'le oluştururken bu
şekilde alırsanız tadından gelmez. Ama
tabii ki gerçek hayatta bunlar her zaman
için böyle gelmiyor. Eee, birçok color
sorunları oluşuyor. Bu aslında birazcık
iyi proje ve iyi tasarım ekibiyle
çalıştığınızda olması gereken senaryo.
Yani color setleri vesaire temaya uygun
şekilde ilerlemeli ama işte bunlar tam
sağlıklı çıkmıyor. Şimdi bu noktada şuna
hakim olmakta fayda var. Ana tema hep
light dark özelinde oynamalı. Yani color
setleriniz, ara temalarınız varsa bunun
önüne oluşturacağınız birkaç tane
extensionlar, color extensionlarıyla
bunları yönetebiliyor olmanız lazım.
Aslında daima temaya uyumlu ama bazı
yerlerde özel colorlar varsa bunları
ayrı bir şekilde yine light dark olarak
ayırmanız gerekiyor. Her şeyi tema color
içine yazılmaz. Şimdi mesela biz bunları
buraya yazıyoruz ya. E burada olmayan
bir şey geldiğinde sürekli olarak buraya
ekledik ama bu da olmaz ki her color
eklediğinde. Çünkü temada özellikle
tasarımcı ekipte çalıştığınızda her
zaman uyumlu olunmayabiliyor. Buna
dikkat edin. Yani ara kalla bunları
yönetiyor olun. Onunla ilgili de zaten
şurada göstereceğim bir mesela custom
extension yazma mesela belki custom
extension yazıp kendi özel colorlarınızı
like ve dark olarak buraya set ettirip
mesela burada güzel bir yapı örneği var.
Mesela mesela bu appt extension aslında
color custom bir class. Yani normalde
mesela color secondary var ama burada
mesela sizin elinizde brand primary diye
bir color var. Bu özel bir tanımlama
burada. Bu sayede buna erişiyor
olacaksınız. Yani bunun avantajı ne
olacak? Her yerde bir daha bir daha git
kardeşim bunu al bunu değil doğrudan
color setini context üzerine erişip dark
light'a uygun bir şekilde kullanıyor
olacaksınız. Ha niye contact oluruz
ileride? Çünkü bu contact zonundan bu
light dark temayı time change yapacağız
ondan dolayı. Şimdi bu burada zaten
anlatacağım ikinci aslında öbür içeriye
girmeden önceki önemliklerden bir tanesi
bu time extension'dı. Bu tame extension
da arkadaşlar özellikle doğru
kurgularsanız ihtiyaç halinde context
üzerinden kullanmanız. Mesela context
üzerinden neden color kullanılır? Çünkü
color property runtime'da değişebilme
ihtimali var. Ama mesela bir context
extension yazıp size koyulmaz. Saçma
yani kolay erişebiliyorum diye size'ı
koymam oraya ben. Çünkü erişmemin anlamı
yok. Amacım o kontekst üzerinde oyun
oynatmak. Eee, ondan dolayı mesela bu
extension context extension yazma konusu
güzel. Şuraya bir tane mesela şöyle bir
tanımlamayla oraya set ettiğiniz için
doğrudan tema üzerinden bu extension'a
erişebiliyorsunuz. E bir de ben buraya
textama erişmek üzerine bunu yaptım.
Yine kartalı da kullanabilirsiniz.
Şimdi eee bu text style guideline'ımı da
başlangıçta burada tanımlıyorum aslında
bakıldığında. Bu font familylerimin ne
olacağı, font size'larımın nelere
tekabül edeceğini de burada
kurguluyorum. Yine dediğim gibi gerçek
hayatta bunlar her zaman eşitleyecek ama
çok büyük olanda eşitletebilirsiniz. Eee
ve bunu ilk projemin içerisinde zaten
temada yediriyorum. Burada önemli olan
kullanımdan bir tanesi bu app size
mesela her yerde elle vermemek lazım. Ya
bazen böyle mesela 16 ya 15 gördün 16
set et ya bu tasarım ve ekip bu bazı
şeylerin olması gereken kurallar
bellidir. Mesela bunları belli yerlerde
tutmak adına heps yapıyorum. Bu temanın
içerisinde değil projenin bağında. Yine
radiuslarım var. Yine çok kullandığım
radius'lar var mesela. Her zaman ya
radius, color, size her zaman her zaman
kullandığımız şeyler ve bunları ne kadar
ortaklaştırırsak proje büyüdükçe çok
önemli. Bunu kullanırken ya isimlendirme
olarak doğru düzgün vereceksiniz ya da
eee üzerine yatacağız. Mesela birazdan
şu page padding'i anlatacağım. Şu page
padding gibi şöyle comment'lerle bunun
ne olduğunu anlatırsanız güzel olur. Bu
colorları zaten söyledim. Yani bu tema
konusu üzerine ben sıfırdan anlatmadığım
için burada refactoring yaptığımız için
aslında bu konu konsept olarak çok
rahatlıkla araştırıp basic olarak
yüzbünü görebileceğiniz nokta. Ben
burada mesela şurada appading'de şöyle
bir classım da var. Eee ama bunu da
göstermek istedim. Bu şekilde mesela
mesela eğer ürettiğinde böyle bir şeyler
yaptı ama aslında bu çok doğru bir
kullanım değil. Çünkü bunu neden getir
yapayım? Zaten constant mesela bu deyip
bunu daha doğru hale getirmek sizin
elinizde mesela. Ondan dolayı bunları bu
şekilde tanımlatmıyorum. Mesela benim
burada app padding diye mesela çok güzel
bir eksinle bir eee extendedim yani
türettiğim ve içerisinde kendi
tanımlamalarımı yaptım, konumlandırdım.
Güzel bir class konuyorum. Bu sayede bu
mesela bu kullanıma gerek yok diyorum.
Buradan atıyorum geçiyorum. Mesela şunu
da şuradan atayım. Şimdi bu basitçe tema
özelliklerim bu. Şimdi burada arkadaşlar
önemli olan nokta skill setinizi ve e
prompt bunu bunu yapmak üzerine bir
promptım üzerinizde var. Skill önemli.
Sikile buradaki tema özelliklerini
verirseniz projenizdeki oluşturacağınız
mesela işte eee tema skilliği özelliği
sayesinde her defasında bir daha bir
daha yapacağınız işlerde buna gitmenize
gerek duymez. Zaten bunları referans
alır ve bunu kullanır. Bu önemli. İkinci
nokta ben yine de projemde bir TEM MD
oluşturuyorum. Bu TEAM dosyasına da
arkadaşlar projenin içerisindeki mesela
colorların işte paddinglerin
karşılıklarını koyuyorum. Neden böyle
bir şey yapıyorum? Çünkü projede bazen
ihtiyaç oluyor. Mesela abi bu renk
neydi? Şu renk neydi? Böyle bakmak
gerekebilir. Sürekli lighta, dark temaya
gidilmesin. Şuradan iki dakika görelim
diye bu şekilde bir yaklaşım da
yapıyorum. Ya buralar okey arkadaşlar.
Yani genel özetle eee hatta promptına
kadar sizin elinizde şu an hepsi var.
Çok rahatlıkla herhangi bir hayatla
kendi projeninize refactor dek
uygulayabilirsiniz. Şimdi biz gelelim
mesela buranın işte mesela basitçe
burada refactor yapmaya. Yine tabii
vereceğim skill setleriyle kullanırdım
ama diyelim ki bunu skill setlerinden
vermiyorum. Benim burada yapacağım şey
arkadaşlar eğer background colorı mesela
bunun beyazsa normalde benim bunu color
temada yani burada benim bir colorlarım
varsa mesela ne app color mesela color
setlerinde mesela bu bunun içerisinde bu
biraz eksik kalmış. Normalde benim
burada colors'ımın içerisinde mesela
şemam varsa ya şemam paletten göreceğim
ya burada geleceğim light paletinden
mesela light palet neymiş? Light
paletteki buradan bulacağım ya da o
temindin içerisinde olması lazım ki
doğru bulayım. Tamam. Diyelim ki hani
buradan bulduk mesela 10 primerymiş
diyelim. Benim e colorım. E bu noktada
tabii darkına da bakmakta fayda olacak.
Mesela 10 primary dark da bu şekildeymiş
gibi. Bunların tabii tanımlamaların daha
detaylı bakarak 10 primer olduğunu
buldun mu? O zaman diyorum ki hocam ben
burada bu context nokta çünkü tema
kullanacağım için app temadaki 10
primerım diyorum mesela. Tema doğru
demedem app tema değil ya bu app
temtemada tabii bak şimdi bu app tema
benim custom yazdım ama ben ana temadan
alacağım için mesela şurada text tema
var oraya ben ekleteyim onu app text
tema şuraya mesela bir tane de şey
yapalım app tema app tematema diyelim
şöyle
team data diyeyim hatta dur
heh
team of dedim şöyle mesela bu temayı
çekeyim mesela buradan şurada Buradan
eptama değil mi? Yanlış mıdık? Şuradan
bir geri geleyim. Bu ha uyuştu tabii.
Team diyeyim şöyle mesela. Heh. Mesela
team dedim. Buradan on color şın.
Buradan color şemasına giderim. Mesela
on surface derim. Buradan alırım. Hatta
bir tık ileri gitmek anlamında şuraya
color shava da diyebilirim mesela.
Direkt git kardeşim bana color shay'ı
döndür diyebilirim. Bu enamları şu
extension daha iyi kullanımda
göstereceğim. Şimdi burada güzel
kullanım olarak yapacağımız şelerden bir
tanesi de şu arkadaşlar. Mesela diyelim
bu flight booking diye alan var. Şimdi
bunu şey yapabilirsiniz. Eee şurada
mesela app temaatex'ten almışım ben.
Bodylch demişim. Hani tasarıma uygun bir
şekilde buradan colorı bulup e
güncellersiniz ve colorlarının da yine
bu şekilde mesela burada bir işte varsa
primary ise setinizi verir. Buraları
güncellersiniz. Tamam mı? Pardon şu text
için konuşuyorum. styleından şuna copy
with deyip copy with deyip şu şekilde
mesela ony deyip burayı güncellersiniz.
Fakat burada önemli olan bir detay şu
arkadaşlar. Eee benim burada size
önereceğim benim yine içeride size
adladığım product text adlı bir class
kullanım. Mesela ben bunu çok seviyorum.
Eee hem böyle ekstra yine text üzerinden
yaptığım bir extens sayesinde rahat
rahat kullanabiliyorum hem de
işlemlerimi rahat yapabiliyorum. Mesela
diyelim ki ben bu product text
üzerindeki ben bunu kullanacağım. Bu bir
bu title. Ben product üzerindeki diyorum
ki mesela şuraya ekleyeyim mesela H1
diyorum mesela buraya da flight booking
yazıyorum mesela kendi kontekstime
buradan eriştiriyorum. Ha mesela diyorum
ki arkadaşım benim kullanacağım bütün
aslında temalarımda tamam mı style
guideline'ımda hani sen kendin bir text
style yollayabilirsin bu buna eyvallah
mesela burada kendi text style ama
aslında burada style almamın bir anlamı
yok mesela bu yine e kodunda yanlış
yazılmış çünkü ben zaten bunların tema
şeyini ben set ediyorum burada önemli
olan şey arkadaşlar bunun copy vt
aracılığıyla bunun ilgili setlerini
verebilmek mesela buraya geldi bu
arkadaş bir dakika Dakika. Ne yaptı?
Temayı aldı. Heh. Şöyle yapacağız.
Temanın içerisinde mesela şu extension
da verdi. Mesela şu şekilde ben bunun
beyazını default'ta verebilirim. Ben
bütün hepsine bunu bu şekilde yaparsam
burada mesela hepsi otomatik olarak
benim tema setimi almış ve kullanıyor
olacak. Bu benim için önemli bir
kullanım. Çünkü rahat rahat ben bu
kullanımları alabileceğim. Bakın şu
süper kullanımlarıyla zaten eee ana
datayı yollamış oldum. He dedi ki mesela
hoca color olabilir olmayabilir o zaman
colorı şu şekilde yollamakta fayda var.
Çünkü color çok kullanılan bir property
genelde. Hani mesela ben buraya color'ı
şurada ezecek bir şekilde de
yollayabilirim mesela. Önemli değil. Ama
mesela H1 işte H3 dedim mesela yine H3'e
gittim ben. Burada şu style guide'a
gerek yok hoca zaten yani bu client'ı
yani bunun ne olacağı belli dedim. Hop
burayı düzelttim. Bu şekilde kullandım.
Bu da güzel bir kullanımdır. Eee tabii
bu şu flight booking böyle yazmayacak.
Bunları da lokalizasyondan alacağız. To'
da atıyorum buraya. Ardından mesela
padding. Yine padding'de demin size
anlattım. App page padding'i kullanarak
e padding kullanarak çok temiz bir
kullanımı buradan alabilirsiniz. Yani
ben buraya gelip elle böyle yazmıyorum
da allum. Buradaki kazandığım avantaj
özellikle constantılı, imutable'lı
kaybetmemek istiyorum. Onun için bunu
yapmış oluyorum. Ya burada mesela artık
bu size'a geldikten sonrasında ben
buraya gelip diyebilirim ki benim app
sizes app size'ım var. Mesela app
size'ım var şurada. Bu app size
içerisinde arkadaşlar şuraya bunda benim
spesifik lengklerim var burada doğru ama
ben buraya gelip şey de diyebilirim ya
hocam spacingleri de buraya atayım hani
en kötü şu en azından burada toplu
olursun diyebilirim hani şöyle attım
mesela diyelim buraları topladım. Ha
burada başka ne var mesela yine burada
text kullanılmış mesela texti body
small'a çektik. Body small'da color
yokmuş. Şunu da hemen color eklettik.
Style guide styleı sildik hocam dedik bu
stylea gerek yok. Hop buradan geldi.
Burayı aldı. Ya ben bunu mesela error
diye bir tane color extension kendim bir
tane belirleyebilirim. Çok kullanıyorsam
eee bir daha bir daha ezmemek için
mesela gibi de yapabilirdim. Ben şu an
sadece kendi senaryoma göre bunları
oluşturuyorum mesela ki hani yarın
kullandığım dediğim senaryoda böyle
benim için hızlıca geliyorsun. Mesela
diyelim bak burada mesela yeni bir
senaryo var. Şunları da sileyim. Minimum
size'ı falan silelim şuradan dostlar.
Mesela burada geldim. Bu kullanıma göre
şurada mesela ben diyelim ki login
aslında login oradan oturdu. Hani bunun
background colorı background colorı
varsa mesela mesela yeni bir ekranın
mavi olması bekleniyor burada background
color olarak. Yine ben şu an orada yok
normalde oradan almam lazım da paletime
gittim. Paletimde dedim ki ben light'ta
maviyi arıyorum. Secondar ha bunun
darkında neymiş diye de bakmakta fayda
var. Mesela secondary dark denmiş. Hani
bunlar tabii daha uyumlu yapmakta fayda
var da hani ben şu anlık şey diyeyim
buraya. Yani bu şekilde ben kullanıyorum
diyeyim. Ya da ben nereden kullanacaktım
mesela bunu? Formatlayayım şurayı.
Mesela benim bir de neyim vardı? Kendi
colorlarım vardı. Mesela kendi colorım
burada app colorım app e temam var. Şu
benim kendi temam. Mesela buradan brand
primary diyebilirdim. Mesela
o background builder mı? Background
color olmasın. Ha yanlış vermişiz gibi.
Yani bu şekilde ben burayı sağlamış
olabilirdim. Şurayı da hatta
centerlayalım. Şöyle olsun mesela şu
logini de e mesela burada yine color
diyelim hocam bak bunun colorı farklı.
Buraya da colorı şuradan yedirebilirdik
hızlıca. Şöyle star guide yine sildim.
Hop styleini attım. Login buradan
oturttum ve bunların hepsi gelmiş oldu.
Şu everyone'ı şey yapamıyor muyuz ya?
Heh. Tamam hocam. Hepsi şu errorları da
temizleyelim.
Tamam. Mesela yine text. Şurayı aldım.
Bunları sildim. Size gerek yok abi daha
eğer bir virgül kaydırmadıysak. Heh.
Mesela yani en basitinden buradaki
işlemlerimin hepsini arkadaşlar aslında
temiz bir hale getirmiş oldum. Tabii şu
şurada refactoring gidiyoruz. Şu an
sadece bu konudayız ama color şemasının
ne olduğunu size burada basitçe yapmış
oldum. Şimdi ben bundan sonra ne
yapacağım mesela biliyor musun? Bunu
oluşturdum. Bu tamam. Benim promptlarım
tamam. Yapım tamam. Oluşturum structure
tamam. Yapacağım tek şey skille
diyeceğim kardeşim git benim iç
sayfalarımı bu skillerle işte maini
falan hepsini düzenle bana bu color
şemayla bunu oluştur geri ver en temizi,
en hızlısı ve bütün şu an production
projelerinde kullanacağınız yol bu
olacak ve bu sayede aslında sizin artık
yeni bir iş geldiğinde yeni bir şey
olduğunda hem performansa hem ihtiyaca
uygun hem de yapıya uygun proje
ekibinizdeki oluş gelebilecek herhangi
bir kişiye uygun yapılarınızın hepsini
kurmuş olacaksınız ilerleyen aşamada
bunların hepsini modülünün altına alabil
olabiliriz ama şu an için burası benim
için oldukça yeterli sevgili arkadaşlar
diyorum. E hepsini yani bir prompllarımı
hepsini buraya attım bu arada hani siz
rahatlıkla şu an erişebilirsiniz. Ben
şunların hepsini arkadaşlar eee şu
dizayn olan kısma da şuraya V6'yı da
arkadaşlar şuraya atıyorum. Eee yani
bundan sonrasında bu kısmı da yapmış
olduk çünkü şunu da sildim. Artık bir
sonrakinde biraz şu vivları temizlemeye
girmek istiyorum. Çok gözüme batıyor.
Sonrasında diğer kısımlara ilerleriz
zaten. Şunu da şuradan GGP yapayım
arkadaşlar. PRını da açtım. İsteyen
arkadaşlar istediği şekilde bu
promptları buradan alır. Yapıyı anlar.
Strctörü anlar. İsterse kendi önüne bir
şeyler ekler ve temiz bir şekilde
projelerini entegre etmiş olur. Sevgili
arkadaşlar teşekkür ediyoruz yorumu
dinlediğiniz için. Umarım işinize
yaramıştır. PR ortada zaten. Kendinize
çok iyi bakın. Bir sonraki içerikte
görüşmek üzere.
Yeah.